another day another review from Lord
addict on the iron Lords podcast today
we're going to be reviewing Valkyrie
Elysium developed by Soul ill I probably
butcher that I apologize if any of them
ever watched this and published by
Square Enix I reviewed this on the
PlayStation 5 and I have a lot to say
about it but before we get off the video
If you guys enjoyed this content
definitely subscribe to the channel we
do pretty consistent content on here we
do reviews we have weekly podcasts we do
a podcast every Sunday at 1 pm Eastern
it is known as the iron Lords podcast
and I actually do my own podcast on here
every Wednesday at 5 00 PM known as the
attic show I want to give a huge shout
out to Square Enix for giving us the
opportunity and providing us with a
review code for this content without any
further Ado here is my review on
Valkyrie Elysium for the PlayStation 5.
let's get it
foreign
[Music]
now before we go on to review this game
let's go over a little bit of other
games that kind of gave me a similar
taste where if you guys like these other
games you might like stuff like this
Bayonetta I felt a little bit of Devil
May Cry in this game so that's the type
of style this game is now I'm not gonna
say it did have a little a couple Dark
Souls elements in it but I wouldn't call
this anyway shape or form a Dark Souls
type of game I feel more Devil May
cryish the story of this game is about
the all father Odin with his last
strength created an embassy of
redemption it's a valkyrie it's pretty
much you're a person that has been
invented by Odin to fight on his behalf
while he regains his stream that's
pretty much the gist of the entire story
now I will say that this story lacked a
lot of elements now there are Side
characters in here there's characters
that you can summon throughout the game
I felt like they could have did a lot
better job boosting these people make
making these people more relevant in the
game now are they not relevant no they
have a lot of backstory behind them but
I do felt like they could have did a
little bit more production wise to make
them a lot more likable now as far as
one of the characters I couldn't even
really tell you the rest of the
characters most of the time these
characters are just something that you
use so you can attack enemies in a more
efficient way one of the things that
really irritate me with these type of
games and I know that people are going
to get a little frustrated when I say
this I hate the dark barrier stuff that
these type of games do think a Devil May
Cry where you get to a certain port in
the map and then bam half the map is cut
off and they're like until you beat
these enemies you can't keep going any
further I don't like stuff like that
make it make logical sense like I
understand that they need that because
you have to progress to a certain point
before you can go into that next room
but it's just like if you're just gonna
block off the areas until I defeat the
enemies that's in that current room just
leave the whole Space open don't blow
lock anything off if I get to the end of
the mission and I haven't really leveled
up any because I just skipped all the
enemies give me that option I hate when
these games try to keep you in an area
to fluff out content that's all this
really is they want you to have to take
the time to beat Those ads or those
enemies in that section before you can
move on to the next section I don't like
that gameplay design now I understand
it's been in here forever but this is me
vocalizing my opinion again get rid of
this just give me the option to run
around in this and that's pretty much as
much as I would want on that now let's
talk about the Hub The Hub is pretty
much a place where you're going where
you actually interact with Odin and you
might be wondering addict why did you
just say Odom because that's the only
person that's here pretty much now the
side characters once you start unlocking
them and you start doing stuff to get
them in your party you will come across
those people they will be in this Hub
world you can do side missions and such
to unlock newer abilities with them but
my thing is you have this giant area and
I I understand in the story lore wise
they do kind of talk multiple times that
there's this great great war between
Odin and then another person I'm not
gonna really spoil anything and it left
the world in chaos and maybe that's
where everyone went they died from that
battle but to me you could have done
better than that fam like I understand
why you're explaining what's going on
but if you're gonna give me the giant
Hub world that actually has a pretty
decent training grounds may I add have
someone be in charge of the training
grounds have me some some merchants in
there that sell me like health potions
and stuff I didn't like the lack of
using other people in this game I felt
like it was one of those things where
it's like they're going to let you go
out there find the people to come back
and do side missions with and speaking
of side missions there's a lot of side
missions in this game you go out there
it's pretty much like a hub World thing
where you see the map you can click over
to the sections of the map and you can
press square and it will tell you all of
the side missions in that area you can
go in there and do them they give you
you know new weapons they give you new
abilities they they give you a lot of
good stuff and you have these little
perk things that you put on your weapons
in general you can also get those from
there it had a lot of content in terms
of getting stuff out did it have any
relevant content content that I want to
do maybe I like how they actually told
you what you get though I hate when
games don't do that like if you're going
to enforce me to do this stuff and
you're gonna put it on the map at least
entice me to go do it don't just sit
there and say Here's a side mission go
do it maybe you'll get something you
want maybe you won't I hate when that
stuff happens but they did a little bit
distant job with the side missions on
here and I can give them critiques for
that kudos to that now let's talk about
the big negatives when it comes to
Valkyrie Elysium on the PlayStation 5 in
terms of the story I didn't like how
they told the story in a lot of
different aspects one thing I thought
was very weird in the selection of me is
like they had like one dialogue for
stuff you would hear the same dialogue
over and over again and what I'm sitting
here going through this and I'm thinking
okay maybe I'm getting somewhere and
they're just repeating the same stuff
they said six seven minutes ago and not
to mention I'm look I'm being real with
you guys when I say this this will be
happening every few minutes every time
you go maybe the wrong way or you go a
different way than you're supposed to
they'll start doing these dialogue and I
would think you know shuffle between
three or four that that's the bare
minimum to me the guys they had the same
dialogue and multiple of these things to
where if you kept going on and you were
there longer than you were supposed to
be they were going to repeat that same
sentence and I'm just like come on man
you could have figured out better stuff
I get it maybe this was a budgeted title
and you don't want to pay a little bit
more money in terms of you know people
coming in and doing voiceovers but let's
let's keep it straight here no one wants
to hear the same sentence over and over
again and then act like it's the first
time they're saying it I've never really
liked stuff like that another thing that
really annoyed me with this game is when
you get the spirits and I'll get into a
little bit more I'm going to try to
pronounce their name probably gonna
butcher that but I can't I can't promise
you anything on that but when you get
these Spirits in your team you have to
do this kind of mission where you push
the analog sticks in and it actually
tells you what direction they're in now
it was cool the first time it was maybe
okay the second time but guys they made
me do this every time I went and got
these people now pretty much how it goes
you do a mission to get these people and
I just didn't like the way it was
structured look you you give that to me
one time and then what you do after that
is you find other unique ways to give me
these people do it in the story wise oh
don't keep doing the same type of
activity to give me these type of spirit
humans that's in the game I think that's
the biggest criticism I can give to this
this game well actually there's a lot of
criticism but this is one of the biggest
criticism it's like they could have
found better ways to do these missions
that made them more enticing because I
was getting tired of doing that now
let's talk about the performance now I
gotten jumped on in the past over
viewers saying that I don't really talk
too much about the performance and when
it comes to this PlayStation 5 for the
most part the game ran pretty solid
there was some occasional moments where
I felt the you know the frames go down
but you know sometimes dramatically but
I wouldn't say it happened enough for me
to actually come out here and state
anything negative about it I think for
the most part this game runs very well
on the PlayStation 5 and I'm very
surprised because there is a lot of
After Effects stuff goes on here there's
a lot of weather effects you know when
it comes to Throwing Fire at people
doing ice abilities they do a lot with
the magic system on this game so I'm
really happy that that all of that
especially when you combine the elements
together to do really crazy abilities
all that doesn't really hit your
performance too much so if you're on the
PlayStation 5 think you're gonna be
pretty good now I don't know about the
PlayStation 4. maybe you should wait for
this game if you want to play that I'm
pretty sure it is on the PlayStation 4.
Now guys let's talk about the bread and
butter when it comes to Valkyrie losing
that kept me going through this whole
game it's the gameplay it's a fast pace
that does have a very detailed combat
system but that makes sense and you can
actually unlock weapons by building and
enhancing and finding magic with the
game known as Divine Arts pretty much
the Magic in the game like I was saying
earlier you can combine them to a point
where you can use one and then use
another for instance there's an ability
where you can actually pretty much make
a magnet and get all the enemies
together and you can cast some giant
fire spell or something like that I
think that the combat in this game works
very well I think that you know think
Devil May Cry it's very detailed very
accurate combat system I wouldn't say
it's a hack and slash it's like the
combination between a hack and slash I
think that you can easily do this game
by just pressing buttons but if you want
to play it on higher difficulties think
of like Devil May Cry you know sure when
you the when you go out the opening of
that game seems very basic seems like
you know there's not a whole lot to that
game but when you actually learn the
combat in Devil May Cry it opens up you
feel like you're in control more than
just pressing buttons and I think that's
the case for most of these games but
this game is definitely the case for
there's a lot of different combo systems
that you can use to really feel like
you're doing something and it's not just
pressing buttons you can go from aerial
attacks to slamming someone down on the
ground to throwing Spears at them
there's a lot of different abilities
especially when you put those other
people the you know the spirits their
names like Angela are probably butcher
that I know I butchered that and it's
pretty much people that died in the past
that they had something that was so
devastating that they that they kept on
them and they weren't able to move on
you can have two of these individuals up
on the battlefield at the time and the
good thing about this is whatever you
use them so let's say that you put the
ice one out then you put the lightning
one out you can actually go back in the
screen and click the ice one in your
sword or spear or whatever weapon you
decide to use in this game that weapon
will have the element of that spirit
that you're using so for instance like I
said you use the lining one and then the
ice one you can go back to the lightning
one and your weapon will have that
element on the outsides of it and why
does the element important the element's
important because this game is a very
very big on Elemental weaknesses kind of
like Pokemon you know when you got the
fire moving you get hit with the water
move you know it's gonna be a bad day so
pretty much how this goes let's say
there's a big ice dragon and the
weakness to ice is fire so what do you
have to do you have to throw out the
fire spirit so your sword can be
embelled with that fire element and then
what they do on here is they throw
multiple different types of ads at you
enemies and they all have different
weaknesses so you pretty much have to
look at the field and find out who's
gonna mess with you the most now
obviously there's more stuff than just
element attacks on here you have Divine
attacks like there's one I did where
throwing a giant spear at someone you
have helling abilities you have pretty
much [ __ ] abilities where you can
actually get people into one area by
grabbing them like a magnet there's a
lot of different spells and weapons you
can use in this game and I would
actually feel like the combat in this
game is very good guys now I'm not going
to go too much into what I would
recommend if you guys buy this game I'll
do that until later but the comment
alone man it's it's good it's good and
I've really enjoyed the time playing
this game now as far as anything else
towards of gameplay the gameplay is damn
near perfect now there obviously there
is issues that I would have in the
gameplay I do feel like you're too slow
to a point I think they wanted to put
the the grappling hook in here as a way
to bridge that Gap in movement speed but
I feel like you could have been a little
bit faster in general and have an actual
sprint button to make sense of your
Valkyrie you're supposed to be a
god-like creature and you're moving
around like you're human it just it
didn't make sense to me in that case I
understand maybe it is design choice
because they wanted the actual combat
system to be so fluid and so accurate
and it's kind of hard to have that type
of accuracy when you move around at the
speed of light and I get that I think
the characters in this game could have
been better I think the villains in this
game could have been better and I think
the story in this game could have been
better but you know what
as bad as some of the areas of this game
was and some of the areas are bad I
think it's a very Blame Game the combat
just kept me in it kept me hooked the
whole time I couldn't put this game down
and I try guys there's a couple times I
was like do I want to keep playing this
game and then I would fight another boss
or something I'm like that was epic so
in terms of that is it worth 60 bucks I
think if you like Devil May Cry games if
you like Bayonetta games and you don't
have a whole lot to play right now I
would say go out there and get it man
sixty dollars you know it's a little
pricey for a game like this but I do
think even though the story was lacking
a little bit to me I think there's still
enough substance there to keep you
interested with the combat system that
they got going in here I honestly feel
like there could be DLC that comes out
in the future of this game so definitely
try that but when it comes to this game
I think that if you like these type of
games it's going to be worth 60 but if
you don't like these type of games and
you're looking for a game to get into
this style gameplay this probably isn't
going to be for you for me I got a
review quote by Square Enix shout out to
them you know they they hooked me up
with a review code and I give my honest
opinion you guys you know I always do
and I feel like this is worth 60 if you
enjoyed this type of gameplay if you
enjoyed this type of franchise in
general keep in mind this isn't the
first one go out there and pick it up
for 60 but if you are on the fence a
little bit and you don't like this type
of gameplay or you've played a couple
and you don't know if this is type of
cut style that you want then you know
maybe wait for that cell maybe wait for
that Thirty forty dollars though but me
I enjoyed it and I think I would have
actually paid sixty dollars for if I
didn't get a review code for it but
that's just me but you know what what do
you guys feel about Valkyrie Elysium did
you guys are you excited for it put in
the comment section below once again I
want to give a shout out to score Enix
for giving me the opportunity to review
this game it was a it was a very fun
interesting experience and that's my
review on Valkyrie Elysium I felt like
this story was kind of lacking a little
bit it performed very well I felt like
the gameplay was amazing pretty much
carried the entire game if you asked me
and I felt like if you like these type
of games if you like that Devil May Cry
that Bayonetta this is the game for you
if you don't like those type of games
definitely pass on it but until next
time this is Lord addict have a good day